we do indeed have a guess Christopher
you is with us after a big victory
against uh Darius Christopher how do you
feel after your first ush championships
it feels really good to end the
tournament with a win especially after
playing having a bit of a rough time and
it was a bit topsy-turvy but
usually it's the last game of the
tournament you remember the most so it
feels really good to end off with a win
absolutely and you've had a rough time
in the last few rounds that game against
uh linear how are you recovering
mentally after those losses
I think I would I just tried not to look
at chess for a bit and just try to get
my mind off
um watch YouTube play other games
but it was very painful so it was it was
almost hard to look at chess because I
was um very frustrated
but I feel like not looking at chess for
a bit kind of helped me regain my
composure
you're only 15 but I feel you are very
mature in your understanding of Chess
psychology of Chess as well who is your
Mentor behind the scenes can you reveal
that who is your coach let's say
I think I have like several coaches for
the moment okay so it kind of goes very
back and forth
um I had like an openings coach
um
and I mostly have coaches that like work
with me with training session sessions
but they're not really full-time coaches
so I don't really have a full-time coach
for the moment got it but you do have a
support system a very strong support
system in your dad and your mom and your
family they're always together with you
would you like to say a few words about
them and to them
I I have to thank them for taking my mom
and my dad for all the support
my mom wasn't able to make it with me
during this tournament but um my dad was
here and I still got support from my mom
so
absolutely and that's so important in
this type of very long events when was
the last time you played such a long
event and was energy ever a problem
I don't think I've ever played such a
long event like this I I think I'm
mostly only played nine round
tournaments maybe 11 rounds but I don't
actually remember ever playing a 13
round classical tournament so it was
definitely a new experience and let's
for a second talk about the critical
moments in this game because you must be
quite happy with your uh performance in
this one how did you approach it did you
wanted to ice the game make a draw or
did you wanted to put some pressure on a
struggling Darius in the last few rounds
I was okay with a draw but I didn't
really want to play for the draw so
right I just wanted to get a normal
position and if he wants to draw it's
fine but if he doesn't want to draw I'll
just play that was the mindset and uh
when did you feel like you took him out
of his uh book his preparation oh yeah
let's go back a few moves
um it was
um so this was still preparation with
takes takes night before but after night
before he spent a lot of time
uh he was probably considering I guess
he's considering D5 yeah Knight C3 is
what he played and yeah I kind of got
inspired because I played this ball
yesterday called and and it only cares
about material and nothing else so I it
kept going H6 B6 C6 G6 Rick H7 against
me and it kept winning and played
against the bot yeah it was like it was
like it felt really embarrassing because
it kept playing like G6 H6 Rick H7 and
beating me
um it's like stockfish but it only cares
about materials so okay especially
that's interesting do you use that in
your preparation in general
it was my first time playing it it was
kind of It kind of really showed me how
much material action actually matters so
as soon as he gave me a chance to take
the pawn I kind of thought about my
experience of playing with that bar
yesterday because I was like yeah
the bottle or Yasser you can play with
the answer he's gonna do the same thing
yeah is going to take all your parts
Knight take C4 D5 and
um at this point it felt like you're
finally I mean taking over the
initiative you are upon up this beach
Pawn B3 after the move D5 is completely
locked out of the game you probably felt
confident at this point yeah he was also
spending a whole lot of time it didn't
seem quite necessary
um like by now I think he already only
had four minutes and it's only move 19.
yep actually nine minutes at this point
after this move Rook to C1 and he was oh
my goodness from eight minutes down to
his last two minutes at move 23. and uh
yeah right now you're just simply
completely winning a nice conversion
after that for you Christopher
congratulations uh for such a good
performance at the USGS championships
the first one in what will probably be a
very long career so congratulations
thank you uh Christopher quick question
for you if you don't mind please uh you
as just as you said this was the longest
tournament you've ever played and it's
also undoubtedly the strongest
tournament you've ever played in you've
got 13 lessons from your first U.S
Championship what did you learn about
these players
I learned that they're very human too
and they also make a lot of mistakes so
if you take them into complicated
positions
um
there's no reason to be that scared of
them because they also make a lot of
mistakes because they're human they're
not perfect machines I like that spoken
like somebody who's ready to beat him up
Christopher it looks like by the way
gratitude well done was the first one
who said this word disrespected this
tournament
yeah I just understood this
started a whole Trend do you realize
that young man what you did uh for our
commentating theme yeah I definitely did
not expect that when I said that because
I kind of said it um on autopilot and
after I said it I kind of realized what
I had done
you definitely opened the Pandora's box
but good luck good luck Christopher uh
and congratulations on this last round
win thank you you're welcome yeah on all
levels